[music playing]
JANE GOODALL: When I
first went to Gombe,
it was the most amazing
time of my life.
DR. ANTHONY COLLINS:
One of the things
which is important for her is to
get away and retouch her roots.
JANE GOODALL: Have
to go this side.
DR. ANTHONY COLLINS: Everything
which is happening today
is because of the experiences
she had in the first.
And she needs to take
strength from that.
Ah, better.
DR. ANTHONY COLLINS: To
be alone in the forest
is what matters to her.
[light music]
JANE GOODALL: Out
in the forest, I
had this very strong feeling
of a great spiritual power
out there.
It was the kind of feeling
that I sometimes have in one
of the old cathedrals where
people have been to worship
year after year after year.
The chimpanzees I knew in the
old days are almost all gone.
But one of the ones who was
my real, I'd say, friend
was Gremlin.
The last time I
actually saw Gremlin,
she came right up to me
and looked into my eyes.
I mean, of course they recognize
us just as we recognize them.
And I've always had a strange
connection with animals.
I connect with
people with words.
With animals, it's
more mind to mind.
So many things in my life
seem to be coincidence,
but I'm not sure I
believe that anymore,
because things happen--
I think they seem to
happen for a reason.
[chimps calling]